la scrittura della natura
opere che nascono dal connubio tra la
mano dell'uomo e le forze spesso
insondabili le forze imponderabili degli
ambienti naturali il ghiaccio l'acqua
il vento la neve opere che si creano
durante il tempo sotto i deserti del
Sahara nelle Torbiere della Patagonia
nelle Foreste di Larici dell'Alaska una
ricerca che è nata molto tempo fa quando
ho deciso di fare un passo indietro
l'artista io che sono nato in un luogo
che forse molti di voi conoscono che la
nostra bella Toscana
nella nostra bellissima Italia un
fazzoletto di terra che è la Valdichiana
Cortona dove queste forze
della natura e dell'artificio umano
collaborano da secoli
immaginate questo paese è uscito da mura
le mura etrusche dove le pietre sono
state scolpite dagli elementi per secoli
e hanno creato una terza bellezza una
terza bellezza nata proprio da questo
incontro pensate Ai Cipressi io Lilli a
tutto ciò che Conoscete un paesaggio
proprio che dal dialogo tra uomo e
Ambiente ha creato bellezza Per una
volta tanto questo è possibile in molti
loghi della nostra penisola ho avuto
l'altra fortuna grande di nascere in una
famiglia dove questo mi è stato
insegnato fin da piccolo questo amore
per l'arte e questa grande passione per
l'ambiente naturale in cui ho passato
veramente molte ore fin da piccolo prima
di quasi Imparare a camminare già
Iniziavo a disegnare il paesaggio e
utilizzato per molti anni dalle scuole
di scena dell'Accademia sono sempre
stato un amante di ciò che ti circondava
del paesaggio naturale in una forma
all'inizio molto realistica mimetica
come spesso avviene per tutti gli
artisti poi lentamente questo tipo di
approccio si è trasformato è diventato
più intimista ma ho sempre durante
questi anni chiamiamoli che
apprendistato
rappresentato ciò che vedevo
ho proposto al pubblico delle gallerie
dei musei delle mostre che ho fatto
qualcosa che io ho visto Ho filtrato più
o meno profondamente dentro di me e poi
ho riproposto un giorno era un giorno mi
ricordo di febbraio di diversi anni fa
Quasi con un gesto di stizza per forse
una mia incapacità forse una debolezza
di non riuscire ad avere un dialogo
veramente forte con l'ambiente che mi
circondava un dialogo profondo Perché se
voi rappresentate un paesaggio anche con
una fotografia un video rimane pur
sempre un interlocutore che non
interviene nel supporto cioè qualcosa di
passivo Come fare a molto Ritratto a una
persona a voltata di spalle Come
rappresentare qualcosa che in realtà non
sa che la state rappresenta
e quindi ho pensato questa folle idea di
prendere una tela come potete vedere una
tela che all'inizio era proprio una tela
pittorica e lasciarla in un luogo
naturale un bosco quella volta è stato
un bosco la tela non era trattata per
una tela che fino al giorno prima e la
stessa tela che per centinaia di anni
Tutti gli artisti hanno utilizzato per
dipingere quello che vedevano Io ho
preso quella telaio e se non posso e
l'ho lasciata lì per un giorno il giorno
dopo Ovviamente quel posto era una
pineta vicino a casa mia la tela era
coperta di abiti di Dio disposti in
maniera apparentemente casuale perché in
natura molto poco è casuale e dopo tre
giorni fiera della terra perché aveva
piovuto dopo una settimana La Terra era
stata spazzata via dal vento ma c'erano
delle tracce di animali che hanno
iniziato a passare la natura
aveva iniziato a scrivere sul mio
supporto un'emozione incredibile poter
interagire e quindi cercare di essere un
po' un Alchimista con quelle dinamiche
tuttora spesso inspiegabili che sono le
dinamiche che creano la bellezza che ci
circonda che danno quel da qui il plus
che possiamo soltanto vedere che nessuna
foto nessun video nessun film potrà
restituirvi è nata qui renatografia
questo nervosismo qua ha voluto dare una
mia ricerca la scrittura della natura
L'uomo in questo caso io agisco un po'
come architetto scelgo le regole e
quindi scelgo dove lasciare il supporto
per quanto tempo fa reagire alla natura
come disporlo quanta profondità che sia
l'acqua come il lago Trasimeno che
vedete alle mie spalle Oppure che sia un
una Laguna in Islanda come quella che
vedete adesso
queste tele bianche trattate solamente
con dei componenti che del tempo ho
studiato completamente Ecco compatibili
che possono essere
mangiati attraversati su cui le muffe
iniziano a crescere le muffe del luogo e
che quindi sono un catalizzatore di
bellezza un catalizzatore qualcosa che
attira le energie di quell'ambiente e
poi Se pensate a poter collaborare con
quello che vi circonda con quella forza
Chiamatela Come volete ognuno di voi
sicuramente nel suo cuore avrà
un'interpretazione personale sia che la
consideri un'entità qualcosa di
panteistico che si muove in un'unica
direzione sia che la consideri un evento
del caso Però ha sicuramente l'idea di
qualcosa di immenso di incommensurabile
che in quel momento scrive su una
materia un tuo supporto e voi immaginate
che fisioterapisti e lo dico con
cognizione di causa la tela è qualcosa
di violabile qualcosa
che tu lasceresti a nessun altro E
quindi in questo caso un passo indietro
che non è un non fare ma è più una città
da fare
dopo le prime sperimentazioni fino a
casa Sono andato a portare questa mia
ricerca l'ha dato l'orografia all'estero
molti luoghi luoghi magnifici come
l'Islanda l'Alaska la Patagonia per
confrontarmi con tutte le situazioni
possibili per indagare e per reinventare
una nuova pittura una pittura fatta
attraverso gli elementi quindi non più
con i pennelli con la longamano sulle la
natura che agiva attraverso le mie
preparazioni che interagiva e dopo una
volta che è una fotografia una volta in
questione si creavano io le guardavo le
osservate
tutorial per sempre per tutta la loro
fase perché erano come paesaggi viventi
che raccontavano proprio
l'intima natura del paesaggio e quindi
un lago non era più uno specchio d'acqua
che rifletteva il cielo ma era qualcosa
di famoso dove hanno cresciute dove gli
animali avevano iniziato a vivere e
altre volte sceglievo il momento più
opportuno le fermate
immobilizzavano lo status quo le
prelevato e le portavo
ad esporre come quelle che vedete e
quindi opere create di Lagune opere
create in Boschi anche lontani da noi
per avere soltanto una minima
impressione di cosa La natura può
dipingere E che tipo di collaborazione
oggi che siamo schiacciati
dall'invasione delle immagini
e spesso ci impediscono di avere un
contatto diretto opere che non
rappresentano ma presenta
il paesaggio opere che sono parte e che
vivono finché sono dentro natura con il
paesaggio stesso
a un certo punto a luglio di quest'anno
ho avuto la grandissima occasione di
recarono a fare questo tipo di ricerca
in Groenlandia Chi di voi conosce questa
questo bellissima terra che è anche
l'isola più grande del mondo sa che il
luogo stiamo parlando un'isola pressoché
disabitata e una delle riserve d'acqua
dolce più grandi del pianeta che oggi
soffre come molti altri zone il fenomeno
del triste flagello del surriscaldamento
quindi un'isola dove lo scioglimento dei
ghiacci è più accelerato rispetto agli
anni che ci precedono causa anche
dell'emissione di gas serra che aumenta
la temperatura
il nostro povero pianeta in quest'isola
ho voluto dato che il ghiaccio come
sapete non lascia una traccia visibile
ho voluto creare naturomasie con delle
carte sensibilizzate delle carte che a
contatto con la luce del sole diventa
diventano blu si chiamano xantipie o
alcuni in poi magari le conoscono
agiscono come un'abbronzatura come
quando vi togliete l'orologio dopo
essere stati sotto il sole e trovate la
traccia così all'incirca una fotografia
io ho voluto creare questi naturoografie
sotto il ghiaccio ma in maniera
particolare Ho letto un articolo del CNR
ISP che l'istituto di scienze polari che
studia il fenomeno dello scioglimento
dei ghiacci accelerato a causa del suo
riscaldamento e ho scoperto tramite
alcuni ricercatori tra cui il viaggio di
Marco è proprio a focalizzato la sua
attenzione su questo fenomeno
L'alga Rossa magari molti di voi non
sanno
anche questa ulteriore notizia riguardo
al cambiamento climatico Ma è un
flagello che recentemente ha
incrementato la giamatorematica
situazione perché come voi immaginate
l'altra rossa
attira su di sé i raggi del sole in
maniera diversa rispetto al ghiaccio
bianco si stacca rossa come vedete è
stato pulando e insanguinerà
letteralmente il distese di ghiaccio non
solo il Groenlandia ma anche le nostre
Alpi anche nelle zone tristemente famose
della Marmolada dove è avvenuto quel
brutto evento questa grossa incrementa
lo scioglimento del ghiaccio non si sa
se provocata dall'inquinamento non si sa
quindi se è diretta conseguenza
dell'azione dell'uomo ma sicuramente ne
è una derivata E cosa ho fatto in questo
ho creato queste opere come vedete
mettendo queste carte foto
sensibilizzate sotto il ghiaccio sano
chiamiamolo il ghiaccio non toccato da
larga Rossa ghiaccio bianco e sotto il
ghiaccio rosso il ghiaccio che è stato
intaccato da quest'alga i risultati Come
sempre quando io crea investimenti
aerografie sono stati
molto per me sorprendenti perché mi
hanno rivelato un aspetto diverso da una
fotografia L'arte è Tra le mille
definizioni che le sono state date anche
un modo di comunicare qualcosa e io
spero anche in forma più potente se noi
siamo abituati a vedere foto degli
accenti che si sciolgono immagini del
ghiacciaio di 10 anni confrontato con
quello di Adesso anche il fenomeno
questo fenomeno diventa qualcosa che ci
anestetizza qualcosa che non risveglia
più attenzione quindi magari un nuovo
modo un nuovo punto di vista perché
credo che l'arte oggi debba servire a
quello può cambiare l'attenzione e
inoltre queste opere sono state anche
appunto visionate dal CNR l'istituto di
scienze polari proprio per dare uno
sguardo diverso a questo tipo di
fenomeno Questa che vedete è una
naturografia del ghiaccio sano come
vedete ci sono le zone bianche che sono
quelle dove ci hanno il ghiaccio quei
puntini che vedete sono le scioglimento
Questa è rimasta 15 minuti sotto 15 cm
di ghiaccio a circa 0,2 gradi e
confrontata con questa che è stata lo
stesso tempo per nella stessa profondità
ma era ghiaccio invaso dalla riga Rossa
Guardate bene la differenza la densità
ha totalmente differente e quindi un
modo non solo divulgativo ma se ha
presentato nel suo piccolo le
potenzialità oggi dell'arte stessa
quando assume una trasversalità che
lambisce terreni come quello della
Scienza dove siamo sicuramente oggi i
secondi a tanti secoli Sapienza in
merito pensate alla Leonardo da Vinci
pensate a tutti i grandi che di questo
hanno fatto oggetto di errori ricerca
secoli prima di noi e anche un punto per
capire come talvolta
se l'arte Sicuramente oggi non ha i
mezzi per salvare la bellezza del mondo
il cambiamento di un punto di vista può
risvegliare una coscienza anche di un
ricercatore magari abituato a lavorare
sui dati abituato ad avere sempre la
stessa visione del problema
è stata un'esperienza toccante toccante
sotto molti punti di vista la
Groenlandia È un luogo abitato dagli
inuit che il nome con cui amano essere
chiamati Che significa gli uomini che
noi chiamiamo peschimenti un popolo
meraviglioso che mi ha aiutato con
significa che come sempre quando torno a
casa io che lavoro come avete capito con
la natura e che cerco il 4 angoli del
mondo
l'essenza di questa natura Cerco un
dialogo perché poi alla fine il primo è
migliore fruitore delle mie opere sono
io stesso Vado per conoscere Io disegno
dipingo scrivo ma poi l'anatografia
questo metodo è l'ultima parola cioè il
contatto diretto dove si fonde
l'ambiente col mio supporto
mi hanno aiutato in questo viaggio e
doveroso concludere con una bella
immagine che mi è rimasta impressa era
gli ultimi giorni della mia residenza
forse proprio l'ultimo Anouk la lo
skipper che viene accompagnava in questo
viaggio tutte le mattine guidano la
barca dentro dei labirinti che
spaventerebbero chiunque di iceberg dove
se tu tocchi e cade in acqua muori per
energia in pochi minuti come la stessa
facilità con cui noi viviamo nel
traffico cittadino
era il tramonto Voi sapete che i
Groenlandia il sole d'estate non scende
mai sotto l'orizzonte però si abbassa
immaginate questi iceberg davanti a voi
colorati di una bellissima luce Rosa un
rosa Perla e il mare come un velluto ad
un tratto a 30 metri 35 metri da noi una
balena una per cui una megattera salta
cavitando su se stessa e alza una nuvola
di vapore acqueo che si trasforma
immediatamente in un arcobaleno
un'immagine incredibile Non resisto Mi
volto apro lo zaino e straggo la Reflex
apro l'otturatore tra due tappo
Moscato
incrocio lo sguardo di Anouk della guida
che non parlava una parola inglese mi
guarda e sorride
Ecco davanti a noi la balena Almeno
adesso 80 metri ha fatto un altro salto
che non ho fotografato ma Di cui ricordo
non indelebile meraviglioso
pensiero dentro il mio cuore
Grazie